[Music]
hey you guys me again time for another
book review
so let's just get right into it now this
is another book that i picked up uh just
like mrs god by peter straub which i
reviewed
last week this is a book that i picked
up at my last uh
trip to the used bookstore uh down in
downtown sanford
where i got like a whole bunch of books
that i'm planning on reviewing soon
now this book right here a little i
believe leisure books used to do all of
these paperbacks
this is by richard layman and it's
called
come out tonight now this book
originally came out back in 1999.
this is actually not the first richard
lehmann book that i've read
i believe i've read this maybe the third
or fourth one i think i read
uh to wake the dead and i think i read
maybe endless night and maybe one other
one
because i feel like in case you don't
know richard layman
who actually passed away many years ago
back in 2001
but there was kind of a time period
where uh him
and other authors like edward lee and
jack ketchum
were kind of um they were kind of
referred to as splatter punk back then i
don't know if that term is still in
use but um that was kind of what they
all
they were all usually mentioned like in
the same genre
just their stories were very very uh
graphically violent very graphically
gory usually very graphically sexual as
well
and there was a time period where i was
kind of like
reading a lot of uh their stuff as i
said i think it was leisure books and
they did like all of these
uh type of paperbacks they all look very
very similar to the same size same
you know fonts same kind of like uh you
know cover layout
so i read some richard layman then now i
will say i don't think richard layman is
quite as good a writer
as jack ketchum or edward lee but
if you like those guys's stuff you will
probably like richard lehman's stuff as
well
now as i said i'm not a huge expert on
his stuff he's written
well he did write of you know at least
30 novels and like a [ __ ] ton of short
stories
and i've only probably read a handful of
those so i'm just kind of going by
this one and the couple other ones that
i read now as i said if you are not
into really really graphic
violence really really graphic gore um a
lot of
rape a lot of like terrible [ __ ] happens
uh a really really lot
of sex very graphically you know almost
bordering on pornographic if you're not
into that kind of stuff
then you will not that i would not
recommend
reading richard layman or edward lee or
even jack ketchum for that matter
because a lot of the stuff in there is
just like really really
really over the top and if it's
something that bothers you um you know
this is not
a subtle genre and this in particular is
not a subtle book by any stretch of the
imagination so i'm just going to tell
you that
right up front if you don't like that
kind of thing you are not going to like
this book
at all as i'm usually saying i find it
difficult to talk about books without
not spoiling things out right but
without like talking about what happens
in the plot
so again if you would like to read this
book even though this came out back in
1999
and if you haven't read it and if you
want to read it and you don't want to
know
[ __ ] that happens in it then probably
turn this off go read it come back and
watch it
watch this after you've read it because
i'm not going to spoil spoil anything
but i do have to like talk about some
aspects of the plot and that may seem
spoilery to some of you
so so basically the setup of this book
the main character is this
young woman who she i think she's about
25 years old and her name is sherry
gates
now she is a teacher or a substitute
teacher or something like that
in los angeles and she has been going
out with this
dude like her new boyfriend whose name
is dwayne
and they've been going out for like
three weeks or four weeks or something
like that
and they've finally decided that it's
time to do the sex
when we open in the book they are at
dwayne's apartment
and uh they're starting to get like hot
and heavy it's like you know there
there's some like background information
it's set in la it's very very hot like
it's in the middle of summer
there are wildfires kind of encroaching
and all that kind of stuff
you know sirens going so it's it's very
like
summer of sam kind of you know what i
made where it's just like it's really
hot there's all this noise it's
you know so it's very like evocative in
that way
so uh at some point during the
festivities
um dwayne has one single condom however
uh at some point it pulls a kaneki and
because he's had it for such a long time
uh it basically like cracks in half or
breaks or something like that
so he's like well i have to go down to
the corner store there's a corner store
only a couple blocks away
they kind of have a back and forth she's
like oh well you know i just
maybe we should do it anyway or he's
like no maybe we shouldn't do this they
have like an argument about that but
finally he kind of goes
um i think he yeah he actually like
drives his van
to the convenience store to buy condoms
and leave sherry there waiting for him
now before he even leaves she starts
having like
almost like weird i don't want to say
like like a weird premonition type of
thing like something bad's gonna happen
but then she's just like oh you know
that's stupid nothing bad's gonna happen
it's gonna be fine
but then she's like sitting there in
this apartment kind of naked hanging out
waiting for her boyfriend to come back
with the condom so they can you know
continue whatever it was they're doing
and she's like wow it sure has taken a
really long time
just to go and buy condoms two blocks
away so finally she waits in the
apartment for like an hour an hour and a
half something like that
and then i'll get into this a little bit
later but instead of doing like maybe
the smart thing like maybe calling the
cops and being like uh hey my boyfriend
was supposed to go
to the store and like he's not back yet
so maybe we
need to investigate she decides she's
gonna go out
uh and walk to the store herself and
see what's what now it's not like the
middle of the night
but i think that i think he says it's
like maybe like
10 or 11 p.m and this is like la and
it's not a great neighborhood
so i'm saying well that was the first of
one of many unwise decisions that this
woman makes
i'm gonna go out by myself at night to
this like sketchy
convenience store to find out what
happened to my boyfriend
so she does that and she gets to
the convenience store and duane's not in
there but she goes in and the guy was
like yeah that dude was in here like he
bought condoms and like
soda or something like that and then he
left but she notices that his van
is still parked there like behind the
store
so she's like huh that's really weird
like where the [ __ ] did he go
and then it so happens that this
kid shows up i think he's like i guess
he's like a high school student so i
guess he's like 17 years old
his name is toby bones and he shows up
and he
recognizes her because he's like oh i go
to foster high school i think is the
name of the school they went to and you
uh subbed for one of our classes once
and she's like oh yeah i remember you
because it's an unusual
name and she remembered seeing his name
in the roll call thing
so then he starts telling her a tale
about oh i saw your boyfriend
like i saw him like walk over that way
like with some other guy and like he so
he starts making up
what is very obviously
not a true story like where hurts like
oh he went off down the street like with
another guy
they looked gay like all this other kind
of stuff
and the the thing about her is that she
kind of buys it at first and then like
later
he's like oh well i lied about that but
actually
what happened was that your boyfriend
like met this like
hot looking chick that he called grace
like in front of the store and then they
went into his
van behind the store to bang and she
buys that too
and i'm just like you don't know this
kid like you know what i mean
like apparently he really was like in
one of her classes that she subbed for
at the high school
but she doesn't like know him so the
fact that he comes up and he's acting
really nice and he's like oh well
if you want like you know i'm pretty
sure i saw him walk off that way
um you know get in the car i'll help you
find him like we'll drive around and
stuff
and so perhaps stupidly
not perhaps stupidly definitely stupidly
she gets in the car
with this kid and they drive around
looking for him
and to no one's surprise who is reading
this book
things go very very drastically
awry now as i said that's just the setup
that's maybe like the first
50 pages or something and from there it
spirals
down into like this poor [ __ ] woman
is and like i said if you don't want to
know anything about the plot or you
don't want to know anything like that
then you know stop listening now go read
the book and then come back because
you know i'm going to say what happens
in the plot and if you don't want that
spoiled for you then
everybody here good with it okay cool so
after being horrifically raped and
abused
at the hands of this terrible terrible
teenage boy who is i mean easily like a
sociopath he's just kind of like our
psychopath
and he ends up like killing multiple
people
uh he kills her boyfriend and cuts his
hat off it's like he does all this other
stuff
now he at some point maybe like a little
bit before like the halfway point of the
book
he basically you know rapes her he
thinks that he kills her and he dumps
her like off the side of a
um like an overpass like over mulholland
drive or something like that so he dumps
her down like a you know
dumpster off the side of the highway now
from this point
she is found by two
teenage boys jeff and pete
and they initially think she's dead and
the [ __ ] up thing about these two this
is one thing that i kind of want to
mention right here no character
in this book is likable
no character behaves except for maybe
one
no character in this behaves like a
normal human would behave
it's just kind of like okay i can see
how toby
you know the the psychopath kid
i can see behaving like that because
he's a psychopath
but one thing when i kind of started to
get into the thing where
okay i'm not really buying this anymore
was when sherry gets found by
jeff and pete these two teenage boys and
immediately
even though they see her she's like
naked she's all beat up and bleeding and
she's like laying at the bottom of this
and they figure it's like oh somebody
dumped her out of a car like off the
side of this
you know overpass and so she's laying
there
and they think she's dead and the first
thing that they think of doing is like
let's turn her over and like look at her
tits or let's like
stick her fingers up her badge like that
kind of [ __ ] and i'm just kind of like
um i know teenage boys in general are
kind of
shitty but i kind of doubt that just two
random ones would be this shitty
and the thing about it is that these two
kids aren't really supposed to be bad
guys because they do help her
eventually because you know spoiler
alert she's not
actually dead she's just like really
beat up and so they do actually end up
helping her
but they're also they're really not
i don't know it's like they're good it's
almost kind of like one thing that i got
from this book was that
you know these kids were supposed to be
like good guys but they were also not
really that great because you
knew you didn't know necessarily what
was going on in jeff's head
but you knew what was going on pete's
head because he was kind of like the
nicer one of the two
and he was like you got like his
internal monologue a lot of times and he
was like
you know doubting maybe we shouldn't
like touch this woman's tits maybe we
shouldn't do this that and the other but
then they would kind of get
talked into doing it anyway even though
he felt kind of bad but he was still
doing it
so i was just kind of like wow these two
kids
are kind of sucky even though they're
kind of portrayed as like
sort of heroes and another thing too is
that when
she wakes up and they you know there's
like a big long extended scene where
you know they take her because she
doesn't have any clothes obviously and
so they take her into uh
pete's house his parents are gone for
the weekend and
you know that he's like trying to find
her something to wear and he's like i'm
just gonna get her a bikini and say that
that's all that i have so they can like
look at her and she's like all beat up
and she's been like raped and [ __ ] like
that
so it's like it's really kind of gross
but
the thing about it though because like i
said i've read some other of richard
layman's books i've read some other like
edward lee that kind of stuff
that's just kind of goes with the genre
so it didn't bother me as much
as it maybe would bother somebody that
didn't read a lot of stuff in that genre
you know what i mean
it's gross but it's like kind of
supposed to be gross and it's kind of
supposed to be
provocative i'm not it's like i sound
like i'm [ __ ] on this book a lot but
i'm really not i actually did really uh
enjoy it but
if you're going to read this book it's
really it's really entertaining
it's really compelling you want to see
what's going to happen next
you know it really kind of keeps the
momentum going
and if you're into like extreme gore or
that kind or
violence and stuff like that then you'll
probably dig it it's it's like a
rollercoaster ride kinda
so it's well done in that way but i will
say
that you need to suspend your disbelief
big time because a lot of the [ __ ] and
some of his other books
i don't know i feel like some of his
other books while extreme
were not this implausible
i guess because the thing is there's no
supernatural nothing it's like usually
these types of books i mean edward lee
does a lot of supernatural types like in
demonic type stuff
but i feel like jack ketchum and richard
layman they are usually more interested
in human monsters in like people that
just do these horribly extreme
things and like exploring that so
there's no supernatural aspect but i do
feel like as shitty as the people in
this
are that's kind of believable like you
know the villains that's believable but
i do feel like the people that are
supposed to be good people
i think they have a lot of like
unbelievably
shitty traits that maybe
i don't know so i felt like a lot of the
characters that even that you were
supposed to like and root for
were not real root worthy you know what
i'm saying we're just kind of like
also sort of mildly shitty too
so there was that issue also i want to
say
that and i saw this when i looked at
some of the other goodreads reviews
because
after i finished it i was curious
because i i liked it in general
and uh i found it entertaining it's a
very quick read um
it's a little long i feel like cause
like look it's like 400 something pages
and i think it really didn't need to be
that long because i feel like
there were a lot of scenes where you
know like i was saying before
with the scene where pete and jeff like
find
sherry and he's like having this
agonizing like argument with himself
over should i take her normal clothes
it's like i shouldn't do that because
then i won't get to see her naked ever
again maybe i should just get a bikini
and say that that's all i have
will she be mad at me so it's just like
so there's a lot of scenes like that
where people's like internal monologues
are just kind of like going back and
forth
and i feel like a lot of that could have
been edited out because it's not really
all that necessary to the story and it's
just making you
read the thing like of the character
being like holy [ __ ] kid you work
you kind of suck you know what i mean so
i feel like that could have been
maybe cut out a little bit more and like
shorten the book up a little bit because
it is quite long
even though it didn't it didn't feel
like a long book it didn't feel like a
slog
although some of the scenes did kind of
go on a little bit too long with
people's internal monologues or with
them going back and forth like having an
argument of like what they were going to
do
and they it seemed like they were
talking in circles and they you know
we're kind of repeating the same things
over and over i'm just like just do
something already
you know what i mean so there was a
little bit of that
now when i read the goodreads reviews i
feel like this was a book
that was either people loved it five
stars they're like oh this was so [ __ ]
up and
you know it was just this crazy ride and
everything which like i said it is
but then the other contingent that were
like one or two star reviews
and a lot of those people it wasn't just
a a case of
people coming in and going oh this was
disgusting and people that didn't know
anything about his work
because a lot of the people that gave
like really really
low reviews were also like fans of his
and it's like you know i've read like a
lot of his other books and this one
seems
one like more unbelievable than some of
his other ones which i'll get into in a
minute
but also some of it seemed like it was
written by like it was a weird
porn fantasy of like a like maybe a 14
year old boy
and it does have a little bit of that
especially when you get to um
about the halfway point where sherry
gets found by the two teenagers
there's a little bit of it in the
beginning where she's dealing with
toby and like all the [ __ ] that he's
doing and like the [ __ ]
crazy murder spree that he's going on
and i get
that most of the protagonists in this
or you know most of the characters in
this are teenage boys
so i guess you are so you're seeing
things a lot of times through
through their eyes or through there even
though you know probably the first half
of the book is from sherry's point of
view
which is another thing i want to say too
is that
sherry um the protagonist even though
she's the victim
she makes a lot of really dumb decisions
like i said
you know at the very beginning her
decision to just go out
like at night in this shitty
neighborhood in la to this
convenience store to find out what
happened to her boyfriend probably not
the smartest
move and getting in a car with a kid
that you don't really know like to drive
around looking for the boyfriend
even after he has told you like a couple
of stupid stories
about where said boyfriend went so it
just seemed like something that no woman
in her right mind
would do um so she made like a lot of
really dumb decisions also i think that
some of the stuff that was written from
her point of view suffered a little bit
from
what happened sometimes when a dude
writes
um from a female perspective like it's
not
it's not to a stage where because i
think there's a website where somebody
like has compiled like all the worst
uh examples of like a dude writing from
a female perspective
it's like where it's like not this bad
but it's like she walked boobily down
the street so you know what i mean
so i feel like a lot of dudes feel like
if they're trying to write from a female
point of view
they think that we're thinking about how
our tits feel
against like the inside of our shirt
like at all times so it's it's
it has a little bit of that it's not bad
it's not like that
distracting i've read a lot worse but it
does have a little bit of that whereas
like
you know a chick is like walking past a
mirror going look how perky my boobs are
and like look how hot i am
like and i'm like most women don't do
that or don't think like that and it
just comes across as like
kind of funny or kind of like an
adolescent male fantasy a little bit
so i think this book had a little veneer
of that
and i don't know how much of his other
work has
that aspect to it because one of the
main criticisms i saw
um you know on goodreads of people that
had only given this one or two stars
that were
fans of his other work were that it
seemed very adolescent it seemed like a
teenage boy had written it
um you know like a lot of the stuff that
went into like was kind of
at that level which i guess i would kind
of agree with to an extent like i said
i've i've read some of his other books
but i don't remember them being
being that bad or that you know
adolescent
but as i said since most of the
characters in this are adolescent boys
maybe that's kind of forgivable
also i kind of thought too there was
like a little bit of a
of a coda like a little bit of a thing
at the end
you know where it was all wrapped up and
all the gang were back together like
talking about whatever
and i thought maybe that he
put that in there to almost make it seem
like because pete one of the teenage
boys that found sherry
was a writer and he like looked up to
hemingway he wanted to be like the next
hemingway
and uh which was one of the things that
made him like go along with all the
[ __ ] that him and his friend were doing
like once they found this you know naked
vulnerable woman like behind his house
he so it almost seemed like he was
trying to make it like
everything had been like this was all
pete's story or we were all seeing it
from his
perspective which i guess
could you know like i said even though
the first part of the book is from
sherry's point of view if she told him
about what happened like he could have
been writing it
like from what she told him so i don't
know if that's exactly what layman
intended
but i thought maybe that was maybe what
that's what he was going for
was like oh well this is all just
actually a book that pete wrote about
what happened you know what i mean like
is what happened to him and then what
happened to sherry because she told him
about it like before they met or
whatever
so i kind of feel like maybe he was
trying to do that but i'm not entirely
sure if that's what that was maybe that
was just kind of like
a little code a little wrap up like i
said all the people were
together and you know we're just gonna
be a scooby gang now and
and go like wipe out all the shitty
people i don't know it sounds like it's
like i said it sounds like i'm [ __ ]
on the book i'm really not i did enjoy
it
you know and like i said the the graphic
sex the graphic violence and stuff that
doesn't bother me because i know it's
richard layman it's
you know if you know anything about that
type of horror fiction that genre
then you know that that's just what he
writes so
that kind of [ __ ] didn't bother me but
it did come
come across as a little adolescent at
times
all of the characters just did really
dumb [ __ ] it's like nobody
nobody in this whole entire book the
whole entire time
called the police i don't think anybody
called the police
one single time in this book even though
like outrageous [ __ ] was happening like
seriously toby would be
they were like an apartment he cut a
dude's head off it's like some woman
came and
be like hey what's all that noise or
something like that and she he just like
jumped on her like in full view of
everybody and just started like stabbing
her
and it's like i don't know if he was
trying to make a comment about oh it's
la we have so much crime it's like
everyone's just kind of blah about it or
nobody wants to get involved
so you know maybe but the fact that
sherry
once bad [ __ ] started happening would
not call the police and
it just seemed like some of the [ __ ]
that she came up with for why they
shouldn't call the police
was just kind of lame it's like so you
know essentially this is
a rape revenge story um you know the
shitty stuff that happened to her
and then she decides you know once she
kind of gets
her [ __ ] together and gets like her uh
her wounds tended to and stuff
she wants to go take care of toby
herself because she's like well
i you know it's kind of a thing where i
don't trust the justice system
type of thing um you know i'm gonna go
get him
myself and then the two teenage boys
because they think she's hot
they want to help her they want to you
know go get him
like you know they they white knight her
essentially um they're just basically
like well you you stay here will go take
care of it even though they're
these two scrawny little teenage boys
and they think they're
badasses and like superheroes and stuff
so it's like nobody they don't even want
to call
her an ambulance when they find her even
though at first she's all like [ __ ] up
and beat up and like they think she's
dead
they don't even want to call an
ambulance because then you know the
naked lady will get taken away and
they'll never see her again
so they keep coming up with all these
excuses like not to call the ambulance
and then even after she wakes up it's
almost kind of like she's like yeah nah
that's fine don't call the police don't
call an ambulance don't you know what i
mean
and it's like they don't even want to
give her the phone like to call
um her parents or anything like to tell
him where she is
so it's almost kind of like honestly how
i thought it was gonna go it doesn't
quite go this way but
i thought it was gonna go that she had
escaped from this one psychopath
toby bones like she got away from him
and then she gets found by these two
[ __ ]
teenage boys and then they decide
they're gonna keep her captive
because they do kind of i don't know if
they say that outright but they do kind
of like wouldn't it be cool if
we could like persuade her to stay here
with us and like oh
like this is ridiculous i don't know
it's ridiculous
but that said it kind of leans into the
ridiculous
so if you if you like this type of thing
if you like
these kind of um just over the top
gory like really really graphic sex this
book is very very
rapey so um keep that in mind if that's
like something that really bothers you
there's a lot
a lot of rape in this so um
you know just fyi if you don't like that
then you probably will not enjoy this
book at all because everybody
pretty much everybody gets raped
multiple times
uh in this and like you know people
force people to rape other people it's
terrible so it's like
so it's all that kind of stuff so it's
very very over the top very very graphic
and as i said a lot of the characters
make really really dumb decisions that
most people in real life would not make
some of the [ __ ] they think some of the
[ __ ] they say is not something that most
people would think or say
but that said if you can kind of suspend
your disbelief
turn your brain off for a little while
and you just want something that's just
like a fun
ride of just like these people going
around la just like
raping and cutting people up and not
getting caught or like no one's seeing
them or like nobody calling the cops or
anything on anybody and they're just
kind of going around
you know wreaking havoc everywhere then
by all means it's still a very enjoyable
read even though like i said it's a
touch long
some of the uh scenes kind of went on a
little bit too long especially the ones
that were like internal monologue that
were kind of just
characters like discussing like their
plan or what they were going to do
i think some of that was unnecessary
another thing too was that it seemed
like it was a lot a lot a lot of build
up
and then the end of it was almost kind
of like they didn't
like he almost kind of like shied away
from it because it's kind of like this
build up where sherry wants to go like
get revenge on toby for all the [ __ ]
that he did to her
and then when it gets to the end it's
just kind of like oh it just kind of
almost happens like off screen
so i thought that was a little weird but
you know what i mean it's
it is what it is um it's not his best
book of the
you know three or four of his that i've
read even though it's been a while since
i've read them
like i said i don't think he's as good a
writer as you know jack ketchum
obviously or edward lee
but um if you like those authors if you
like things uh along that line and are
willing to
just sit back and be like yeah whatever
it's like you know what i mean because
[ __ ] like this it would not happen like
this in real life
but you know you could say that about a
lot of thriller movies and stuff like
that he's always going to have some kind
of
aspect of [ __ ] you know people doing
dumb [ __ ] like
to kind of serve the plot so i think
there's a lot of that going on in this
book but if that
sounds like it's not going to bother you
or anything like that then by all means
pick it up it's
you know like i said i just kind of
bought it randomly because i saw it at
a used bookstore and i had read some
other stuff of his and i was like oh
that sounds like a
you know kind of an entertaining book to
read and it was very entertaining
um so if that sounds like something that
you would enjoy
then uh check it out it's called come
out tonight by the late
richard layman like i said came out in
1999 so
not really any cell phones a couple
people had car phones and [ __ ] like that
but
no modern technology or anything nobody
has gps and
nobody knows where anything is it's just
kind of like funny to read about now
like so where is that address how are we
gonna find out you know what i mean
whereas like now you'd be like pink and
you can find it anywhere so it's just
like kind of funny to
read stuff that happened back then uh
but yeah so i guess that'll do it for
this tomes of terror and i'll see you on
the next one
bye